I got miss Wow can't see it that is
being me notes vlog miss and so I just
took a shower and I just wanted to
update you guys on that um I decided
that I video vlog missed for today sorry
is this is so boring and I'm like doing
nothing this is super boring um you know
some days I vlog miss are gonna be much
more boring because I'm a human some
days they don't plan out interesting
things are you guys to see as if I'm
living them authentically and some days
I do this I took a shower so I'm really
alright I apologize I'm so same
disgusting looking right now even though
I'm the cleanest I've been in weeks
oh my all of a sudden I'm doing vlogmas
and it's Thursday night and I thought I
would take you from tonight through my
day tomorrow just like hey like do you
think hate hair sometimes it's a give
your hair you're just like yo hair
alright weird I know so I'm doing vlog
this just for today well today into
tomorrow I have like such a busy day
tomorrow it's crazy I like can't even
handle it I'm gonna take you guys along
with me and show you all the parts that
I only want you to see none of the parts
in which I seem to see you vapid or oil
anything other than like totally
grateful and happy I love you oh I
forgot to say I love you [ __ ] my dog
yes look cuter guys just look cute oh my
god yes look cuter why is she sleeping
in her like dog hostel I don't know
she's just so weird you're so weird
oh here's what I'm wearing to bed I know
anyway I got the move well I was talking
hey I'm doing vlogmas and tomorrow I'm
going to take you on the road with me
I'm gonna do podcasts tomorrow also
we're on to the garden apologist maybe
unless I freaked out about what could be
happening down there and cancel it
last-minute who knows so get ready for
that otherwise I'm just gonna brush my
hair like stuff loathe for a little bit
and just like reflect on the idea of
like I'm not a whole person I'm just
kind of being the parts that I think an
audience wants me to be I might just
watch like black mirror tomorrow
all right I'm running man so I'm doing
vlogmas today because it's long this
time
it's like 7:50 a.m. right now which is
like absolutely horrid and disgusting
hair dried like this it's just
disgusting I think I may have a spider
bite and my thumb
oh my alarms going off yo help a key dog
still sleeping in there one sit with me
last night we have a great relationship
oh look at that ooh I hate this angle
today oh there's an optician that's
coming to my house this morning to fix
an outlet because I bought the wrong
dryer and I don't know a washer and
dryer
hence the sweater garbage bag that way
but I'm gonna make coffee so I thought
I'd show you guys me making coffee
because like no one's ever made coffee
I'm sure they've ever witnessed with
your eyes before so I thought I'd be
like the one that shows yourself along
with coffee here we go oh my god this is
like still like blog leg front rows yeah
your old mug has a photo of my dog on it
because I am sad and one-dimensional
okay update we're doing vlogmas
electrician didn't come to fix my outlet
for my dryer he was like running an hour
late and I didn't have time so we have
to reschedule
so no guess who doesn't get to wash
their clothes or says it doesn't have to
wash their clothes for a couple more
days dance dirty [ __ ]
and now we are heading to the
gynecologist clearly I'm very
comfortable talking to you about that
how's your day going Shane care to say I
love you I love you if you're not
subscribed please subscribe we're doing
vlogmas because i just thought you guys
deserve it I love you and I love you too
also I love you but not in the way that
I love like I real love like internet
love you know where I just say it and
the word means nothing my vlogmas quick
update um all my lady bits just got
poked and prodded and everything was
rock-solid now never done is not rock
solid but I meant like good vaginas
everything's a party down there a good
clean fun party like a Mormon
the ring down there what now let's go to
fullscreen and podcast yeah Diana's
holding court okay we're on set now for
now too deep and that's really excited
Jackie exciting I'm doing vlogmas I'm
doing one day of vlogmas and today it's
not a close-up view of the set here it
is okay cool this might give you a hand
gesture who's our first guest table but
you probably already know follow me on
Twitter if not you should there's that
it's all very exciting business and it's
also very dangerous Jesus Christ log man
I've augmented still vlog man we just
wrapped our first podcast episode and
guess who was on it horse winking and I
learned about his love of Celine Dion
and his like not so much love of whales
no oh yeah and their trip to Bangladesh
oh my god guys so much Kolchak a bug man
yeah Magma's yeah yeah i block miss
updated still blog man now I finished
podcasting I didn't even show you the
second guess was I'm just like the worst
youtuber of all time I only tell us to
pick up my camera and capture seemingly
authentic moment and I did Emil Sherman
and he was an absolute joy a pleasure a
sweetheart and inspiration and icon a
legend anything else that you want to
call him he is all of it an hour and
like that fun traffic heading home or a
go home as he goes my dog dog miss
wouldn't be blog miss on anyone's
YouTube channel without the Cameo of
some sort of animal animals do really
well involve very scalable I guess
especially the snakes aha and then we
might go bawling and do karaoke snake
sound like alone no no it's some friends
you'll see or not maybe I'll just
continue to shoot second blog mass iMac
haul before I came home my Amazon Prime
now some dog toys because I knew that
this woman be upset that I was gone all
day she is ripping the back off of a
hedgehog right now so just like cute and
savage I'm eating some snacks look
here's a fun new snack that I like a lot
I look gross but
I don't care what I see vegan cheese dip
at 365 which is all foods brand branch
of a grocery store that they just built
out here
it's like spicy queso dip that's vegan
and it's really good and then I bought
this at the sturdy spoon grape why not
mix them together and eat them with
chips so that's what I'm doing vlogmas
update plug life is so crazy and that
makes me interesting right like it's so
hectic that is this the kind of dinner I
have to have isn't that like charming
and like relatable but also like
aspirational chips and dip are good like
60% of my diet it's the Sun no wrong hi
reporter look less dead everyday my face
looks closer and closer to Kid Rock
hi mom is it still on miss and when DJ
Diaz just upgraded my hair yeah
extensions clean hair full hearts can't
lose
so at the end of this blog massive vlog
um even though I did not upload this on
the days of they intended to upload this
I enjoyed this experience and I miss
blog go what if I I actually do love it
for the rest of the days leading up to
Christmas how many days is that day what
day how many days if it's too many days
I'm not gonna do those days but if it's
not too many days and I'm gonna do the
day okay it's the twelve by the time you
see this that means that there are no no
yeah you want to vlog this let's blog
miss I say okay should we bother me
let's vlog miss we're gonna vlog miss
love madness
yeah yeah that seems yeah you know it's
a good decision when you don't
confidently agree with the decision that
you've come to so it's vlogmas
up until Christmas don't forget to
subscribe to this YouTube channel
because vlog miss and also I don't know
perfect nailed it